welcome back to the show let's go to
this week's mailbag an increasingly
popular segment with the lovers and the
haters of the david pakman show you can
email info
davidpakman.com please don't abuse the
email address guys there's so many
people that we just have to block from
our email and filter their emails to
where they belong right into the trash
but it's still great hearing from from
so many of you before we jump into the
email piece let's do like one little
extra which is a tweet response and this
goes to remember my monday segment about
i'm no longer going to
uh apologize to the idiots sort of thing
here was like i tweeted about russia
this week and someone wrote back dude
you're regurgitating cia talking points
what a loser take um give me a break
dude go away i don't care what you think
and i'm not doing the show for you you
can go away find some show
that uh is more pleasant for you but we
i just don't care i just don't care
um i've had the other one is you're
regurgitating dnc talking points man
we're not paid by the dnc i have no
contact with anyone at the cia i don't
even know what cia talking points are
when it comes to this
i just don't care the show is not for
you please move on no longer explaining
away or apologizing
corey wrote in and had a very good
reminder corey said what happened to
obama gate sir at one point trump
declared obama gate as the crime of the
century he never detailed it but claimed
everyone knew what it was and the
evidence was going to come out i know
that it's just part of the trump griff
but when these claims never come to
fruition how do otherwise intelligent
people keep falling for this well
they're not really otherwise intelligent
corey is it a matter of personality cult
brainwashing or do people just want to
be insiders and pretend to be in on the
grift there's different reasons why
different people fall for obvious lies
yeah if you don't remember the whole
obama gate thing trump at one point
started using that term obamagate and
saying it's the biggest political crime
of the century
and a lot of people
would ask like reporters
what is it what is it and trump would go
you know what it is
and would attack the media and the
evidence was always just on the brink of
coming out and of course like it never
did it never did come out
and um i don't know what obama gate was
was obama gate them they spied on my
campaign
was obama gate the tan suit was obama
gate when trump when obama had a
particular type of mustard on a burger
uh i don't know at this point what obama
gate was supposed to be but rest assured
it doesn't exist
it doesn't exist
a very strong shot across the bow fired
by ralph
ralph wrote in and said harry situation
david no politics in this email
i just wanted to let you know that your
facial hair
is much better than farren cousins
not as good as brett ehrlich's though
i love your show watch it every day on
youtube keep up the good work this is
extraordinarily divisive
extraordinarily divisive and i would
encourage ralph to rethink write in
about something less divisive like you
know the israeli-palestinian conflict or
something like that no in all
seriousness i can barely grow a beard so
i don't even know i i did not expect any
commentary on my facial hair
um nor do i have anything to brag about
quite frankly i i just this is what when
i don't shave for two weeks this is what
it looks like and it's pathetic and
that's okay
um but that's it i don't have anything
else to add about that
will rhoden about trump's presidential
portrait says hey david really enjoy the
show and the way you discuss news almost
all of which i agree with
one small point i don't agree with you
on
is marjorie taylor green's use of
gazpacho instead of gestapo i in no way
support her on anything
but i do think
she said gazpacho on purpose
to ridicule pelosi to attract more
attention into rhyolous libs it was not
a slip of the tongue or an indication of
her ignorance as if any more were needed
i disagree and the reason i disagree is
number one i don't think marjorie taylor
green is smart enough to think of that
and number two it's not really helped
her in any way that she has been widely
ridiculed for saying gazpacho instead of
gestapo
it's not gotten more people to agree
that nancy pelosi is the mask gestapo or
whatever it is that marjorie taylor
green meant to say uh i just don't think
so and a couple of people have proposed
some version of that theory
i i just i just don't think she's got it
in her and
later in the email and i apologize that
it got cut off the topic is trump's
presidential portrait will went on to
say
do i think that biden will welcome trump
to the white house to unveil
his presidential portrait the way
prior presidents have welcomed their
predecessors
i think the answer is no i do i don't
know why or how it will work out
this way
but i do not expect to see trump at the
white house
having his portrait unveiled with biden
standing there i don't expect it part of
it has to do with trump continues to say
he actually won the election and that
biden's not even the rightful president
so i don't expect that to be the case
if you disagree with me
let me know
uh toby wrote in
toby says i remember way back in the
1980s and 1990s when tv news had
commentators they would generally
announce whoever it was is a commentator
have a message on screen announcing that
is what they did
i figured this was to separate them from
the journalists i find it interesting
eventually doing it this way was done
away with therefore blurring the lines
between journalists and commentators
yeah this is a very astute um
observation
right now
many so-called news channels are based
on the idea that they blur
reporting and news and fox news does
this expertly
they will for example not identify
that we have now shifted from me giving
you facts to someone giving opinion and
unfortunately a lot of people are too
ignorant to realize that that shift has
taken place
they will often
crowbar in opinion into their news hours
by saying so here's like a way it might
go on a thursday night tucker carlson
will go
it looks to me like the fbi might have
done the january 6 trump riots
of course that's an opinion not based in
any fact the next day fox news hours
will go
last night on his program tucker carlson
stated that he believes the fbi
and then like now let's bring in two
people to debate it did the fbi do the
riots or not
and it all becomes part of the news
cycle um yes
it would be much better to go back to
those quaint moments here to give us his
opinion which is not the opinion of this
network and it is only an opinion is
tucker carlson or what you know whatever
the case may be
toby uh absolutely spot on observation
joseph rhoden and says david sir your
comparison about high schoolers asking
questions to milton friedman versus the
modern day high schoolers asking
questions to ben shapiro is apt
but i think it misses an important
detail so background what i said was
you can see the decline in sort of
education and competence
in that if you look at high schoolers of
the era asking questions to milton
friedman or noam chomsky and you see the
questions asked of ben shapiro
or or college students
that
it the caliber has declined dramatically
and i see it as a sign of the
anti-and pseudo-intellectualist movement
and uh the decline of education critical
thinking etc joseph says any high school
that would invite ben shapiro
is probably not turning out the
brightest students in the first place
talk about academic standards therefore
it stands to reason that the questions
from these students would be
inarticulate let's be fair you know okay
so that's fair i mean i guess the idea
here is
someone who would want to go see milton
friedman speak
is by definition going to be more of a
thinking person than someone who would
want to go see ben shapiro speak i don't
know i mean there might be something to
that there might be something to that
but i think
part of the issue part of the decline is
in
who
people want to go and see speak
and uh
i think that there's been a dramatic
change there as well so a fair point but
i don't know that it really tells us
everything we need to know
damien writes in and says about the
midterms david why does everyone assume
republicans will take back the house in
22
despite the fact that democrats took
back the white house and senate in 2021
well first of all it was 2020 but
that is why so damian here here's what
you have to understand
if you didn't know
the history of american politics you
might think well democrats did well in
2020 so by definition they have momentum
going into 2021 uh 2022 not the way it
works historically
when one party wins back the white house
in one election year in the next
immediate midterm the other party takes
back control of the house and or senate
or extends their control
and we can talk about why that is often
there's sort of this idea of a pendulum
that when it swings one way it then
comes back and swings the other way a
lot of different reasons but
historically that's the way it happens
usually when one party takes the white
house they then lose the house and or
senate so that's why we expect it to
happen and indeed it is looking that way
unfortunately last email is from glenn
glenn says david love your show but
i'm not a fan of you referring to mike
lindell as pillow
he's definitely an unhinged man worthy
of your ire but by referring to him as
pillow i feel that you're lowering
yourself to trump's level of using
derogatory nicknames for those that
displease him
though pillow isn't really that
derogatory just appears unseemly beneath
you i would prefer you refer to him by
his real name i kind of disagree listen
pillow is not a serious person mike
lindell is not a serious person and part
of making it clear that you know it's
not
senator mitt romney has taken a position
on tax reform and we're not going to
call him mittens right
i would agree with you there
pillow's not a serious person and the
fact that mike pillow has even gotten a
place in american politics thanks to
trump who was also not serious
i believe
at every level
we need to be ridiculing the fact that
this guy has a voice and so i think in
his case referring to him as pillow is
absolutely fine um
anecdotally i think people in the
audience tend to agree with me
on that one if you disagree
by all means let me know
we also have a great bonus show coming
up for you today the bonus show is for
our website members we depend on website
members to fund this show you know we've
got cpac going on right now
and cpac is wild cartoonish reactionary
extremism and we should laugh at it but
but but but remember
cpac should also be a reminder
at how much more seriously the right
takes
funding
organization
for right-wing media and right-wing
politics okay on the left
we stink at it the right crushes us with
funding right with me wing media funding
right-wing conferences so remember
let's support
media we think is doing something
valuable if you think this show is doing
something valuable consider getting a
membership at joinpakman.com it's very
cheap and you'll get access to the daily
bonus show every day you'll get a
commercial free audio and video feed of
the full show
every day six hours before it publishes
for everybody else and
you'll be supporting something that
hopefully you think is worthwhile sign
up at joinpakman.com we have a coupon
code you can use if you want that code
is wow 22 wow 22. we will see you on the
bonus show in a moment